conférence de presse qu'on l'avait
annoncé d'ailleurs avec des coups de
tambours attention demain c'est un
conseiller a growth conférence de presse
de la nasa pourquoi voyez ces photos
extraordinaires parce qu'on a trouvé de
l'eau sous forme liquide
on avait déjà trouvé de la glace sur
mars lassé de l'eau sous forme écrite
pour nous expliquer tout ça on est allé
chercher le spécialiste travers la
montagne bonsoir à vous d'avoir un
physicien vous êtes directeur exécutif
de l'observatoire du mont mégantic donc
de l'eau liquide sur mars
c'est important comme des gouvernements
oui découverte très intéressante ça
vient confirmer qu'il y a présentement
de l'eau sur mars
on savait que j'en ai déjà eu dans le
passé dans un passé très lointain les
traces géographique morphologiques
indique que eu des océans des maires des
lacs des rivières mais c'est tout a
disparu s'est asséchée et la disparue
mais le fait qu'il y ait de l'eau
présentement au moment où on se parle il
ya des mécanismes qui font en sorte que
l'eau est utilisée pour recréer des
caractéristiques de surface c'est très
intéressant parce qu'il ya donc de l'eau
présentement dans cette eau là on ne
sait pas où on sait c'est la question je
pense il ya des de la matière vivante
qu'idiot dit fisc des petits poissons
mais ce cas des petites bactéries des
petits organismes
on a on a aucune confirmation qu'il y a
de la vie seulement c'est un ingrédient
très intéressant quand on recherche de
la vie nécessaire quand on quand on
regarde la vie sur terre il ya une
association très nette entre la présence
de vie la présence d'eau sur bodoï a pas
de vie mais la présence d'eau n'est pas
une preuve formelle
de la présence de vie mais c'est une
indication dans la bonne direction mais
on dit on dit beaucoup aujourd'hui c'est
de l'eau excessivement salée donc est-ce
que ça empêcherait une forme de vie à
l'intérieur de l'eau non pas du tout si
tu nous cesser de l'eau de mer
extrêmement salée le même
par comparaison le loup de mer sur terre
serait presque douce
c'est donc une autre est salée mais il y
a des formes de vie même sur notre
planète qui tolèrent et en fait qui
préfèrent des environnements que l'on
appelle extrême que ce soit des extrêmes
de température de pression ou même de
composition chimique comme la salinité
donc il peut y avoir une forme de vie
primitive sur mars
tout à fait on peut imaginer que
lorsqu'il y avait beaucoup d'eau sur
mars dans le passé très lointain des
formes de vie aurait pu se développer un
peu comme ça s'est produit sur la terre
qu'elles ont graduellement disparu au
fur et à mesure que l'eau dispersé mais
on imagine qu'il ya des poches d'eau des
nappes phréatiques sous la surface de la
planète
il peut y avoir encore tout un
microcosme bactérien à cet endroit là
que l'on pourrait tenter de déceler ça
reste très art et de l'oci vous si je
prends votre verre d'eau et que je vous
téléporte sur mars
l'eau va s'évaporer très vite très
rapidement dans caire en quelques
minutes elle va se mettre à bouillir la
pression atmosphérique est tellement
faible que l'eau va se vaporiser très
rapide
l'autre question qu'on se pose c'est
doux g7 ou sur martel vient du ciel y
pleut ou quoi non c'est une excellente
question on n'a aucune idée de la
provenance de c'est tout et c'est pour
ça qu'on soupçonne ces nappes
phréatiques
on pense que toute l'eau de mars n'a pas
totalement disparu cannes encore une
partie qui est piégé liquide sous la
surface et que parfois elle perd cole se
vaporise ya donc une faible vapeur d'eau
ou une humidité dans l'atmosphère de
mars qui viennent mouiller les sels
minéraux et qui les fait glisser qui les
rend liquide de sous forme de cette
saumure très dense en terminant sur la
montagne
cette découverte va faire en sorte qu'on
va encore plus intéressés à mars est
absolument déjà ce que c'est ce que ça
nous révèle c'est que s'il ya de l'eau à
l'état liquide sur mars ou qu'on peut en
trouver les futures missions habitées
vers
vont devenir nettement plus intéressante
beaucoup plus facile à réaliser ce à
dire au plus vite mais ça va coûter très
cher mais ce sera plus facile parce que
déjà on aura un ingrédient extrêmement
utile pour la survie des astronautes sur
mars qui sera retrouvée sur place
on sait tous maintenant on fait tout ce
qu'on peut savoir pour vera le mystère
reste entier pour le red road à montech
merci de ce fait plaisir
enfin